at this Hospital in keev they are all
set for a second winter at War the
basement air raid shelter able to
accommodate 200 has just been
renovated it has its own well to provide
a source of clean drinking water in case
the main Supply
fails and it now has a third generator
to ensure a constant electricity
Supply the power Cuts were quite
frequent in the area last year the
medical facilities were the last ones to
be turned off and when they were our
generators coped with the
situation as the cold weather sets in
Ukraine has been strengthening the
resilience of hospitals and other
essential facilities as temperatures
continue to fall the authorities believe
it's only a matter of time before Russia
launches an allout attack on Ukraine's
Energy System as it did last winter and
it's not only the big cities that are
preparing for for the onslaught even the
smallest of villages are getting ready
to the north of keev the village of
mosan saw some of the fiercest fighting
of the invasion when Russian forces were
stopped here and then forced to
retreat Yuri Yenko like other residents
is preparing his store of firewood his
home like many others was destroyed in
the fighting it will need to be
completely rebuilt he tells us last year
he and his neighbors had to sh through
the winter in plastic container
homes this winter they have better
temporary houses that he aims to improve
further by installing a wood
burner measures both big and small to
help ukrainians resist the double
threats posed by Russia and winter Rob
McBride Al jazer
ke make sure to subscribe to our channel
to get the latest news from Al
jazer